the program of the evp
bears the Union's signature in Germany.
and what we have adopted here today,
is a clear message
to voters in Germany
for freedom,
for security,
but also for prosperity
and thus for competitiveness in
of our industry,
maintaining all objectives as a matter of course,
which go with it 1,
in particular to manage climate change,
to achieve the Paris goals.
but we also say very clearly and very clearly,
this can only be done with a strong economy,
with a competitive industry,
then we can build 1 strong social Europe,
then we can also get out of Europe
a major contribution to climate change,
to solve this great problem of mankind,
contribute.
and that is our intention
and we have that today also here in large
Conformity
formulated with each other.